hello everyone and welcome to another HD
tutorial and in this video I'll be
showing you how to get the visual
tooltips effect just like you have in
Windows Vista in Windows XP now
obviously I can't do the whole tutorial
on the installation of it and everything
because I have Windows XP but this is
Hurley will just be showing you a little
bit about the visual tooltips and then
I'll give you a link in the description
on exactly how to get this for XP so
first thing you want to do is go to the
link in the description which will
happen to bring up this website right
here and you go you hit this download
now' button right here and if you really
want to you can look at all the pc world
reviews and the user reviews to see
exactly what everyone thinks of this but
this is basically a clone for Windows XP
of the visual tooltips so I'm just going
to minimize the Safari for beta but make
sure to check out my Safari for video if
you haven't already so down here you'll
see I have actually four different
separate programs open in my taskbar one
is the Safari 4 that I just minimized
the second one is actually 6 notepad
documents which I'll get to then I have
the I have a wallpaper of this Firefox
window and last but not least I have a
Microsoft Word document
now you'll see exactly when I hover over
them you see a little preview that's
built into Windows Vista and this is
exactly what you're trying to get as
well as on the top of it you can see a
little name of it now when I hover over
the documents over the notepad one
however you can see that you can't see
every single one like Windows 7 you
actually have to click on it and then
move up into it and see the little
preview here they're not very long
notice except for the last one which is
full of video ideas and then you can't
actually click on the preview like in
Windows 7 but again I can't wait to go
into some and show you guys that but
exactly when I click on the note then
it'll pop up and you can see it's just
the last sample note so enjoy that
visual tool tips for Windows XP again if
you like the little tool tips that you
get little preview windows in the bottom
of Windows Vista they're gonna like this
because this is almost an exact clone of
what you're getting in Windows Vista
especially made for Windows XP so thanks
for watching this HTC
toriel just a quick little tip for you
guys and I hope you find it helpful if
you have any other video requests or
tutorials for me just help go ahead and
subscribe and send me a personal message
and we'll get back to it thanks for
watching peace